good morning there we go
morning everybody going to open up the
uh today's executive session uh welcome
back to everybody we have a new member
of our committee representative Frack
joins
us Laura will say a couple words in a
few minutes we also have a
substitution um Mary hackin Phillips did
I say that right uh it's actually hackin
Phillips the best way to remember hackin
is to think of a computer hack got it so
very good I hope that helps so Mary
hackin Phillips has joins us today uh
representative
stavis thank you Mr chair I'm very
pleased that uh representative hacken
Phillips is able to join us today and
delighted that representative frat is
here for the first time um he won a
special election in Enfield back in
August I believe uh and he is one of the
newest members of the House in the
Democratic caucus so please help me in
committee okay we have six retain bills
that we're going to go through today
hopefully uh the first one we're going
to open up uh hearing on uh executive
session on house
Who ah
Donald getting a little ahead of myself
uh
please
present gu thank you clerk is here
represent L Alice here representative
Kelly representative award present
representative Brown here representative
here representative Tetro here
representative TR
11 here representative Gilman here
represent majori here representative
Gallagher here representative hockin
Phillips here representative Howland
here representative priest here and
representative frch here and Mr chairman
okay now we will open up the executive
session on House Bill
70 and recognize Vice chairman
power thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
2023-2024
thank you Mr chairman so this amendment
is the same amendment that was offered
um previously in our executive session
for this bill this bill um clarifies
that the deputy town clerk must be a
resident of the
municipality and additionally the um
strikeouts put both sections 41 4 1
colon 18 and 669 colon 65 in in concert
with each other um further clarifying um
um the
reason that that the town clerk the
deputy town clerk should be a resident
is that it's it's very clear
that the deputy town clerk shall be
qualified in the same manner as the Town
Clerk and the town clerk must be a
resident so um we heard during the
hearing the Secretary of
State testified that both the the the
Town Clerk and the deputy they um must
be residents due to privacy ISS issues
um they're responsible for recordkeeping
Vital Records births deaths marriages
adoptions they're also responsible for
matters related to registrations and
Licensing and additionally they're
involved with elections so they made it
the Secretary of State made it very
clear that both positions must be
residences that they must have their
residence in in the town
um New Hampshire Municipal Association
also supported the amendment to to
clarify um the
statute so
um if there's
no if and then the important thing is is
that if
the
clerk is unable to perform the duties
for for various reasons that the deputy
is to fill in and the big problem with
the bill I meant the big problem is is
if the deputy were to needed to become
the clerk they would not be able to to
participate and run the elections so
it's this amendment is is important it
clarifies that the deputy be a
resident
amendment seeing none
there go uh represent T go ahead thank
you Mr
chair
um since the town clerks are are are
elected the deputy town
clerk still can be appointed
by the
Selectmen
and how do you how do you get around
that part of it because the requirement
is that they in the in a state con
Constitution that uh Town clerks
elected and it
does from what I've read
the selectman
can appoint till the next election but
then the next election person would have
to
that is there any other comments from
the floor representa Gallagher um so
um this bill was originally a bill by uh
representative
adjutant uh I'm wondering um who is no
longer with us um and who whose seat um
representative fact is now filling um
I'm wondering um did you discuss this
bill this amendment with the uh original
sponsor and um if so what did he have to
it representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the question yes um I discussed the
question with the uh clerk the house
Clerk and he informed me that even if
the member was no longer a member of the
house that the bill needed to be
disposed of by this committee
but that the prime sponsor was no longer
here therefore there was no need to
consult with the prime sponsor well I
mean maybe not may I follow you need to
be recognized represent yeah may I
follow up representative go all right so
even if there isn't
a technical need to consult with him I
was just wondering more out of just a
general courtes
to the um former representative um I
mean if I left the legislature and
someone took up one of my bills for me
after I left I would want to be
consulted about it regardless of um
whether it was necessary or
not thank you representative any other
comments before we call a vote on this
seeing none
or Senate McDonald would you call a roll
call
2023-the yes cler votes yes
representative lales yes representative
Ella yes representative Kelly yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro
no representative TR
11 yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori
yes representative hackins Phillips
yes
yes representative priest
yes representative
Fran
yes uh motion passes um 19 to
one do we have a further motion
representative
power thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass as amended on House Bill
PRI further discussion on
priest thank you any further
discussions seeing none we'll ask the
rooll okay uh hb70 otpa uh Vice chairman
in power yes representative Guthrie yes
collect votes yes representative silus
yes representative Ella yes
representative Kelly yes representative
aood yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis yes representative Tetro
no representative T
Len yes representative Gilman yes
representative
yes representative
Gallagher
yes uh representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
FR yes and Mr chairman
to1 thank you uh without objection this
will go on the consent calendar is there
any objection to to that uh
representative Gallagher you objection
or well just a myor clerical note um so
uh I believe I was skipped on the roll
call for the um for the amendment on it
um I mean you it sounded like you
recorded me as yes which is how I would
have voted anyways but I just wanted to
make sure that um you had your notes
correct there before thank you for the
clarification
yes I do have him as a as a yes on the
adopt the amendment so you're okay with
that representative gager uh yes just
making sure okay thank you okay
uh the report representative power will
be writing the committee report thank
you that closes the executive session on
hb70 and we will roll right into the
executive session for HB
[Music]
202 and do we have a motion from
representative
power thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass on House Bill 202 thank you do
we have a
second yes I second the motion um we're
going to uh Representative stavis makes
hb22 representative power which would
you like to speak to your amend uh
motion yes thank you Mr
chairman um the house bill 202 this came
out of a commission
um from a bill in 2022 it was House Bill
411 so the commission was tasked with
two things first to study the
equalization rate used for the
calculation of property tax abatement
and also to establish a meth
method to equalize Market values for the
purpose of calculating property tax
abatements so the problem is that
there's an inequity because two
different Equalization rates were be are
currently being used they are um a year
apart one is used for tax ass assessment
purposes and the other one is used for
tax appeal purposes so this committee um
was charged to
establish a method to eliminate this
inequity and which which they did so um
this house bill 202 represents a much
needed uh solution and this is for th
for these brief reasons I could say more
um this bill um should be um ought to
pass thank you representative any
further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
once he is ready to call the
rule on the motion of OTP on House Bill
202 thank you Mr chairman uh OTP
hb22 uh representative power yes
representative
Guthrie clerk votes yes representative
Salis yes representative Keller
no representative Kelly yes
representative aard
yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis
yes representative Tetro yes
representative Trey
11 uh representative Gilman
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher
yes representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
representative PR yes Mr chairman yes
motion passes 18 to
one 181 and one absent is that correct
yes thank you
um representative power I assume you
will write the committee report for that
and again without objection it'll go on
the consent
calendar seeing no objection we'll do
that and that will
202 and with that we'll open up the
executive session on HB 270 relative to
the election of straford County
Commissioners um I'm going to make the
motion on this one to
itl uh representative power would you
like to Second yes I second it thank you
and I'll speak briefly to it as
everybody knows the contents of hb70 uh
270 were U moved into
hp75 and went from the Senate to the to
uh House of Representatives and then
over to the governor which he signed so
there's no need for HB
discussion seeing none we'll ask the
cler callor
role okay uh it HB 270 uh representative
uh Vice chairman power sorry yes
representative Guthrie cler votes yes
represent lales yes represent Jo
Kella yes representative Kelly yes
representative aood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro yes representative TR 11 yes
representative Gilman yes representative
yes representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
franch yes and Mr chairman yes passes 20
to
zero thank you uh I'll write the
committee report on that and again
without objection it'll go on the
consent calendar any
objections I see none it will be on the
consent calendar that closes the
executive session on
[Music]
hb27 next up uh we'll open
up ex ex session on HB 313 relative to
the reductions of the default budget for
official ballot Town meetings and I'm
going to recognize representative yella
with an possible
Amendment thank you Mr chair I would
like to move uh Amendment
2023-24
15h uh thank you do we have a second on
that I'll that representative McDonald
seconds uh 23 uh 2315 H you said yeah
thank you
representative thank you would you like
to speak to your Amendment
you I would thanks
um
so um I guess beginning history on this
was um that
I we um retain this bill because of some
kind of confusion I guess with the
language in the original bill regarding
um uh
turnover and um really the issue that
I'm trying
to um solve is
when when the facts on the ground and
the in the Community are being served by
a particular person um and they're
they're currently working in the job
that the the default would reflect their
actual pay
um and um I it was brought to my
attention um that if someone let's say
uh was currently working in a position
providing the services to the town um
for for
um for example $100,000 and then they
left and a new person was hired and
working in the job maybe not as senior
um for only $70,000 or
$75,000 the def and the default budget
for that following year that first year
of that new person's employ the default
budget would be $100,000 even though the
budget being asked for is actually only
70 or 75 to reflect the person's actual
pay that's getting in that
position um and uh that didn't seem
right and then also I was talking to
representative magori about about this
issue and it actually comes up also when
you
um hire for or you're proposing an
absolutely new position let's say for
$100,000 because you don't know what the
person will actually be um hired at you
just put some placeholder number in the
budget so that the the voters have an
opportunity to approve that um position
and uh then let's say that the voters do
approve that position at the $100,000
but then you go and hire someone and and
actually it's only $80,000 for the
person that is hired and they're working
on the job that next year's budget they
would be proposing an $80,000 to to
fulfill
that that role with a person that's
currently working there however the
default budget would still be the
$100,000 which doesn't make a whole lot
of sense um and so my uh attempt with
this amendment is to um essentially
achieve that uh that those people that
got hired at that uh potentially lower
rate would be uh
that the default Bud budget would
reflect that and so the language that I
put in um to clarify that is that that
the um the default budget would be
reflecting the actual salary and
benefits of filled positions therefore
if the position was not filled let's say
someone just left uh that you wouldn't
want to adjust that um that amount um
because you still need to have that
money available to be able to hire
someone um and so only for filled
positions um at the time of the uh the
public
hearing you would have the default
budget reflect those those positions
salary and benefits um and then also
excluding any um um raises or anything
that you did in mid year since the last
time you had a budget uh p ask for that
so if the if the selectman for some
reason decided you know mid year that
they're going to give the town uh
administrator a 5% raise or something
mid year that wasn't approved by the
budget uh by the voters then that
wouldn't be part of the default budget
that it would just be the the pay the
last time and then they can propose that
raise in the in the new budget um
there's also on line seven uh language
that is the difference between the two
amendments um that language is just the
adding of by law to this phrase um and
other obligations previously incurred or
mandated by law so it's it would read
and other obligations previously
incurred by law or mandated by law um
this I don't have super strong feelings
about but there was some concern with
the um that some towns are essentially
um interpreting this phrase to say other
obligations previously incurred and then
being able to put something in the
budget even if it it's not required that
it is incurred let's say the Selectmen
decide that they're going to buy a new
back ho and they agree to buy the new
backhoe is that uh an obligation that
was pre previously incurred by the
Selectmen right and they in in my
reading of the language technically that
would defeat the whole purpose of a
default budget and I don't think that
the the courts would actually allow such
um such a thing to happen but the person
that raised it to me um thought that
this language would um clarify it
without them having to sue the town for
for um their interpretation of this um
other obligations previously incurred um
so if the uh so that's why I'm proposing
uh this committee so thank you thank you
representative yella uh representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Rella for that very long
and detailed explanation of your
Amendment um however it does nothing to
address the basic fact that our current
governor has said that governance works
best at the local level and this
amendment and this B Bill does nothing
but extend the heavy hand of conquered
into the individual deliberations and
budget approval processes of towns and
cities across the state assuming that
they're all buying somehow legal back
hose um that their citizens do not know
about um the fact of the matter is that
a budget is proposed and the voters
approve that budget so by the
legislature interfering with that after
the fact we would actually be negating
the will of the voters and I find that
um a very frightening Prospect and for
that reason I will be opposing this
amendment and opposing the Bill thank
house well I would take issue with my
esteemed colleagu definition there um
the problem we
face is if the will of the
voters is to turn down a
budget that they feel is
excessive then the provisions of I
believe it's 2 provides for a default
budget which is a fall back
position to allow for the town or the
school district to continue their good
work even though the voters have
disagreed with the proposed budget and
have turned it down so the default
budget
is my interpretation is a fall back
position to allow for the business to
continue now what we're
facing is that towns and school
districts are
manipulating the rules on the default
budget so then in many
cases the default
budget rather than being a fallback
budget is is actually
higher than the the proposed
budget so my question is if the voters
turn
down the de the proposed budget because
excessive but the default budget is more
than the proposed budget how is is that
people thank you further comments
representative Gallagher actually um
just this is a clarification question so
I was noticing um we have two separate
amendments from representative uh yo
here for HB 313 um could uh we just be
reminded here 2015 um okay um yeah uh
okay so the first one then all right got
P thank you Mr chairman um I support
this amendment and I'll just make two
brief comments with regards to online
seven by
law that those words incurred by law
it's it's it's it points to something
that's that's that's optional
that if this
obligation
exists it's it's
following a law with it's following law
with regards to a
contract
Etc
and the also on line seven where it says
or mandated by law that that's a mandate
that's that's something that says this
this you must have this so I support
this particular Amendment over um
2316 and my second comment would be with
regards to you know the main idea and
purpose of this amendment is that it it
it speaks to and it has to do with
default budgets and in my mind it gives
clear Guidance procedurally with regards
to these default budgets and it makes
complete sense
as um my prior colleagues have explained
who do support this amendment I don't
see that it overrides the will of of the
people and I think I believe that the
issue is is that
[Music]
some subdivisions are
not are
not dealing with the default budget
properly and and and this just gives
guidance that that these things um shall
be considered
and when calculating the default budget
amendment representative majority thank
you Mr chairman and I I want to uh
extend my thanks to representative Kella
for for reaching out we did have a good
conversation about this and I absolutely
understand where you're coming from and
actually when I look at the language
that says uh by law um I do reflect on
and those of us who are members of
Select boards and budget committees in
this room and I think a lot of us are
are probably going through the process
right now of setting your budgets for
those SP2 towns and if there were some
instance where um the select board were
to have proposed a raise for some
non-contractual position in town um I
could see where that raise would not be
allowed to go into default and I would
think that that might happen and I could
see where if this says by law that this
would prevent that and I think that
that's a good idea um however and with
all due respect to my friend um I can't
support the amendment because or the uh
uh yes the amendment because in Long
conversations with my finance director
he said and I'll use a specific example
we have a position in town that is
posted for
$110,000 if we were to hire that
position at say six months in and only
pay
$55,000 he would have to default the
actual salary and benefits because
that's what it says now I know I think I
know what you mean but he would only be
able to default what was paid rather
than what was budgeted for and defaulted
the next year it would auto correct auto
correct to whatever was actually paid
but in this instance we'd be losing half
of the salary that was available and any
Del in that salary if there was any
would fall to the fund balance which
then could be used to offset taxes or
other reasons why the select board or or
the other reasons why the select board
can use it so in in those lengthy
conversations I had with my finance
director he saw several problems with
that language although I see where
you're
going thank you Mr chair representative
kahill did you still have a
comment they're all pointing at me
representative
TRV um default default budgets make me
crazy let me the member will suspend of
course um we've
had a conversation multiple times in
this committee on how I go
about recognizing individuals I guess we
need to have it again what I do is I
look around the room and I saw your hand
before representative trevan but I go
from Democrat to Republican to Democrat
to
Republican you were
next as a Democrat after representative
majority I looked over to my right
because Mr representative kale Hill had
uh had his hand raised he decided not to
speak so then I recognized you now
chair the configuration of our room
makes um anybody sitting in your chair
uh challenged in seeing those of us on
your Corners so you know we'll we'll be
sure that you notice us um and I know
that you do default budgets make me
crazy I'm just going to lay that right
out there and I do my best to understand
them as a member of this committee and a
member of the public and I I think I've
gotten to a better understanding my
issue with this amendment is I have
heard several people um on my colleagues
on this committee explain that it's
their
interpretation or or they ascribe
motives to voters or they say in my mind
these are notes from when you were
speaking and as far as I'm concerned any
Amendment or Bill that is continuing to
be open to your interpretation that you
need to explain to me before we even
voted into law I can't imagine what will
happen if we voted into law so I'm I'm
sorry I can't support this it's not
clear thank
you of you Kell did you have something
else thank you
um I think that
the
that the um interpretation that the
language actual salary and benefits for
filled position means that the actual
um not reading the plain language of the
bill um if if the person let's say in my
example before was getting paid
$100,000 and they left and for um you
know on December in December and the new
person is hired in January and they've
only been working for three months then
uh uh
situation the number would actually not
be reflecting that new
person's um salary and benefit with that
interpretation right it would be saying
okay 80% of the year we paid $100,000 a
year for this position and 20% of the
year we paid 75% and so then we're going
to add up all of those actual payments
and and that's going to be the default
budget I don't believe that that is
the um plain language of of refle in the
actual salary and benefits of the filled
positions the those people agreed um and
signed you know employment contract or
whatever they agreed to be um paid the
$775,000 or or whatever and I believe
that the language in this
amendment would allow for that agreed
payment for their actual um salary
to continue I don't believe
that that you know if if you um let's
say in the example of a firsttime
employee you you budgeted at $100,000
but you only hired them two days
beforehand uh before the public hearing
that you're going to only be able to put
a default budget of two days of pay that
I believe that is not um reflecting the
actual salary and benefit of the person
in the position right and so that uh it
doesn't say the actual reflecting the
ACT salary and benefits of um paid for
that position right it's the actual
salary and benefits of that
position and so I just disagree with
that that person's interpretation and um
so I think the the plain language of the
the bill um supports
my um conclusion thank
you representative
Hollen so at the risk of stating the
obvious you don't want to use your
default budget the the whole reason that
the budget process is so long and
hopefully transparent is because you
actually want to pass your budget and
doing things like padding the default
budget only adds distrust which
undermines the whole process of trying
to pass your budget so so most
municipalities I know would never do
that the whole idea is you're trying to
convince your community that this is a
good idea that it's fiscally responsible
both shortterm and long term so when I
look at this I agree with what uh
representative maiori said the act the
term actual is the problem because the
ACT you know an example that we had that
we wanted to replace a Parks and Rec
director any one of your management
positions at the municipal level
especially in this hiring climate is
going to take multiple months to hire so
it's unlikely that the actual salary
that you did that would be budgeted that
was actually paid out would be the same
as what you did there the second thing
is to uh representative stav's Point
municipalities already have the
opportunity if you have that $100,000
position and you only fill it with an
$80,000 position the unused money then
goes into your fund balance which then
allows the municipality the flexibility
to then give it back to the voters to
reduce the tax rate what what this
really does is make a really difficult
situation any community that is going
into default budget is in crisis all of
their long-term planning which may be
road construction
infrastructure uh equipment is all
thrown off and meanwhile inflation is
going along so those items are getting
more expensive and so there's a
disconnect that's occurring between your
community and your governing body and so
the real thing that goes forward is not
just the focus on the default budget but
actually fixing your budget process so
that you can actually pass a budget and
so this really makes a challenging
situation more challenging it takes away
the flexibility of the community by
stripping their ability to use those
those funds uh in a way that is best for
the community so so I do not support
this I I do not think it's a good
lales I would just like like to address
representative howland's statement with
concerning uh uh the need for the
operating budget and for the community
to be in line with the with the uh
governing body so that the budget is
well known and
transparent by the community so that
they can pass it now my question is if
we have a community that says spending
is too high whatever you're doing
there's too much money going in the
budget and they make the decision that
as a community that we're going to we
want to spend less in the form of uh uh
for the
government well what do they
do if they vote down the budget but the
default budget is more than the than the
proposed
budget then we just keep going and going
and going and the will of the community
thwarted representative Howen again so
to that point that's why you have
elections so obviously if the municipal
body is not following the will of the
people they would not be elected again
so um so they do have a choice I mean it
would be the subsequent budget okay if
your budget fails and you go into
default when you're proposing your next
budget if you're sane you're not going
to come with a padded budget you're
going to try to cut the budget so in the
subsequent budget that was proposed I
would assume it would be a much lower
budget and then the voters would vote on
the much lower budget and that would
solve your problem so there are
safeguards in place to allow those those
addressed further comments or
questions on the amendment
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
um I also have problems with the I think
uh follow up on representative howland's
comments um currently it's is a unique
time in several ye over several years
but it's not the only time that there's
been a recession or or constraints on
how much we can spend because of uh
empty positions that we cannot fill for
a substantial period of time and uh and
I will give you an example we have three
department heads and the the they've
been vacant for six months and it's
because we cannot afford to pay uh what
the going rate is for somebody of that
skill level level and if we adopt this
we will never be able to fill those
positions because they will be stagnant
at the level that we have right now and
I so I can't support this because uh it
will make it difficult for uh the
town represent your color thank you um I
guess reiterating the language of the
bill it actually has no effect on on
vacant positions um and
the uh if the proposed new budget um for
let's say a vacant position was um
inadequate the budget committee could
propose a higher
um line item for that that position even
though it was vacant um there's nothing
in this that
would would stop that and actually if
the VAC the position was um not filled
then it would stay the same amount that
it was approved by the voters the prior
time um but it seems like there is um
some concern I guess that the
municipality um is
not able
to
uh is is going to have trouble dealing
with the default budget um
that that uh the the town voters decided
to give them and I think that is
um the town voters have no recourse for
affect ing the default budget they can
go to the town uh deliberative session
they could amend the the the um proposed
budget to whatever they choose as long
as it's within the um I think it's
10% um but they have no recourse for
what the amount is of the default budget
they cannot make a motion to change the
default budget at deliberative session
and so what is in the default budget is
what is already mandated by law we
aren't putting additional burdens on the
municipality by saying this is what is
to be in the default budget we already
mandate that that is that is the section
of law that we are currently addressing
is it's already required by law that
this and not that is in the default
budget and the
um the lack of clarity between
municipalities for example if someone um
as as someone that is on a b budget
committee would agree with um the fact
if if the selectman decided to give a
raise midyear that was outside of the
budget um budgeting process after the
budget was passed um and they you know
transferred that from another line so
that they could give someone a raise
that is not part of the default budget
and should not be part of the default
budget if it is being interpreted by
some municipalities that um that that
raise that they give midyear is an is an
obligation based on their reading of
this then I think that there needs to be
Clarity um for that because that is not
the
purpose of default budgets the default
budget is to essentially like uh my
colleagues said is that the that the
functions of the government can the that
the town have previously approved can
continue and with the language that I am
proposing that position that is
fulfilling that function of government
at X dollar can continue at X dollars
not at uh an increased dollar amount
that is um not appropriate for
fulfilling that function
anymore because of the situations on the
ground have changed and that position is
now being served by a person making that
new amount and so I think that that
reflecting of that in the default budget
is appropriate thank you further
comments did you have comment
representative Tetro no you were looking
at
me I'm sorry do you have do you yes
um I don't know if you can do this in in
committee but seems though we we've
heard the same pingpong match here
for quite a while and nobody's
changed anybody else's mind so I would
request no request needed I was getting
ready to do what you're G to ask
so so seeing no further comments on the
amendment uh we'll ask the clerk to call
the
role HB 313 adopt Amendment 2023 2315 H
Vice chairman power yes representative
Guthrie clier votes yes representative
as silus yes representative yella yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Ard yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes Representative
stavis no representative Tetro no
representative TR Len
no representative Gilman no
representative ma no representative
Gallagher
no uh representative hackin Phillips no
representative howling no representative
Priest
No Representative franch no
and Mr chairman
yes uh motion fails uh
9-1 thank you Mr Clark do we have
another motion on the underlying bill of
HB 3113 representative yella no I saw
representative Major's hand up first
representative
majori with all due respect to my friend
and with the intention I still would
move itl on HB 313 thank you
representative savis I see your hand up
for a second Is there further discussion
on the underlying Bill seeing none we
will ask the clerk to call the
role uh representative power no
representative
Guthrie clerk votes no Representative
lales no Representative yala no
representative Kelly no representative
award no no representative Brown no
Representative
kahill
no representative stavis yes
represento yes representative T 11
yes representative Gilman yes
representative maery yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative hacken Phillips yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
franch
yes and Mr chairman
no itl passes 11 to9 thank you Mr clerk
uh so this will go on the regular excuse
me the regular calendar um for the
committee report um representative
majority and we
will represent yala um yeah the
the minority motion would be a to pass
amendment yeah we can we can talk about
that yeah we'll talk about it but we'll
have you valid motion we'll have you uh
write that okay so that uh closes the
executive session on HB 313 represent
majority I'm sorry Mr chair No my only
question is then does the does does my
report reflect just the underlying bill
itl just the bill just the bill okay all
right
thanks okay uh next hopefully this will
be a nice quick one HB 433 providing
property tax exemptions granted prior to
a home sale shall not be applied to new
owner open up the executive session on
that look for a motion from
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
I'd like to make a motion to uh itl HB
433 FN um the prime sponsor asked us to
do this we need a second before you can
speak to it represent McDonald
seconds now uh representative kahill
would you like to speak to your motion
yes uh the prime sponsor asked us to um
itl the bill so we're following her
request thank you m representative
kahill any comments questions
representative
Tran thank you Mr chair um
representative kahill any explanation as
to why the sponsor wanted it to be
ited
no ma'am oh thank you
sir further comments or questions seeing
none we'll ask the clerk to call a
roll HB uh 433 FN
itl Vice chairman power yes
representative
Cy cler votes yes representative Salis
yes representative
Kela yes representative Kelly yes
representative aood yes representative
Brown yes representative K Hill yes
representative stavis
yes representative Tetro yes
representative Tre
11 yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
frat yes
and chairman turkot yes motion passes 20
to
zero thank you Mr clerk uh
representative kahill will write the
committee report and unless there's any
objections it'll go on the consent
calendar without objections so be it
that closes the executive session on HB
FN okay uh looks like we have one more
to go uh open up the executive session
on HB
FN and the chairman will offer an
231h do we have a second on
that I'd like to second that
representative kahill seconds that
Amendment um I'll speak to it
briefly uh few weeks back um several
interested parties uh contacted and
suggested some uh new
language um that language was discussed
back and forth uh several times and
after multiple edits it came to uh what
you see before you now in uh
231h uh basically what this does it's uh
uh a small bit of an an enabling but
it's also uh meant as clarification
language um much like another bill that
I'm sponsoring this year uh where the
attorney for the commission says
something is allowed but then the
individuals going around inspecting or
say it's not allowed um that bill will
be a clarification bill and I believe as
written
this this uh gets the point across that
representative Bickford the original
sponsor was attempting to do basically
what it will do is allow
municipalities to use pretty much what
they would like as long as it's on their
class four and class five highways they
can still use uniform police officers if
they want they can use uh flaggers if
they would like again it only applies to
municipalities and their class four and
five
discussions represent
Guth thank you Mr chair what what would
happen to communities that don't allow
flaggers that they they have determined
that any
uh any need for uh for for this kind of
service would be provided by police
officers
if that's a question to me basically
what this amendment does it gives the
municipality the ability to do pretty
much as they see fit does that answer
your question yes well I I think it does
Mr chairman but I every time I see a
shell on a
local um bill it really concerns me I
don't see why the towns can't do this
without the bill and I don't know what
the need for it is is if it isn't
uh I read this is if there's a work
being done on a street and it's not a
heavy traffic
Street uh but uh they want particularly
if it's a a
utility uh they they want somebody there
we we uh we in our town at least would
provide a police officer and under this
we don't allow Flags in our town and
under this amend it and the bill as I
said this is an enabling and clarifying
bill it would allow your municipality to
continue using police officers so if you
choose it would allow the use of uh
flaggers under certain SI situations if
you choose uh on line nine you'll see it
says the use of uni uniform police
officers shall that's the only shall in
this in this
bill um everywhere else there's there's
a May and there's a should which are
less restrictive the the
sh is only required when the
municipality has determined and it goes
on to list
several uh several issues so basically
it's saying under these certain
circumstances you shall use them but the
decision is up to the m the uh
municipality
ultimately I don't mean it that way Mr
chairman but thank you you're welcome
thank you further question
representative majority thank you Mr
chairman and just for clarity for me um
if if the if the municipality was
challenged their determination do you
see where it has to be a a formal
written determination that's sent to do
or is this the select board determined
that according to we need a police
officer or the highway department
determined that due to these reasons and
just have something written do I I see
no requirement in there for that I would
think that a m
municipality uh would have some sort of
written
uh process or whatever that they would
use to determine that this does not
mandate that but I would assume any
municipality would do that
representative
Gallagher um so I'm comparing the
um the amendment against the original
language
um and so I personally do not see the
amendment as an improvement over the
original um I think the original wording
was better um I'm someone who's
concerned about um police brutality and
I think the original wording doesn't
does a better job of um restricting the
Le the use of police as flaggers and um
you know a lot of times when there are
instances of police brutality it's from
traffic stops which comes from cases
like when they're being used as flaggers
so um yeah
I for for that purpose um yeah I uh um
oppose the amendment but support the um
underlying bill without it
though for the
comments I have one more that I forgot
to bring up um this was a subject in
2015 of a uh Senate Bill 234 that
established a commission to actually
look a study uh study committee not a
commission uh to look at exactly this
issue and I just want to read you the
final
recommendation uh it says the committee
recommend the bringing forward of
legislation that would give authority to
the municipal governing body to adopt
ordinances regarding the use of flaggers
or police stal details relative to
Temporary a traffic control the
legislation would limit the use of
police to only when specific safety
concerns occur or if qualified flaggers
are not available so I I believe
this the amendment does exactly what
that study committee was looking for but
further comments
questions seeing none we'll ask the
roll thank you Mr chairman uh HB 526 FN
power did did you say the motion uh to
pass uh
amend oh okay
yes my apologies Vice
chairman Representative guthy no clerk
votes no representative sales yes
representative yella yes representative
Kelly
yes Representative aood
no representative Brown yes
representative kill yes representative
stavis yes representative Tetro yes yes
representative Tre 11 yes representative
Gilman yes represent majori yes
no um representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes represent of
French okay um Mr
chairman uh yes uh motion passes uh to
to4 okay
um since the amendment passed I'll go
ahead and I'll make the uh motion of um
HB 526 OTP as amended do I have a second
on that representative kahill yes I'd
like to second that motion thank
you further comments
seeing none we'll ask the clerk to call
the
role uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
no uh click votes yes representative
sales yes repres Jo
Kella yes representative Kelly yes repr
award yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis yes represent Tetro yes represent
TR 11 yes representative Gilman yes
represent majori yes representative
Gallagher uh could you just remind me
what the motion is again OTP as amended
okay
yes representative
Hicks I'm sorry my apologies represent
hland yes representative priest yes
Representative
yes motion passes uh 18 to1 17
um I'm not questioning the clerk's
represent got through you or
no were there any other
NOS there were no other NOS oh okay very
good 1801 very good all right then uh
without objection that'll go on the
consent calendar and representative
turot will write the committee report
that closes
HB 526 executive session I'm sorry Mr
clerk I I thought I heard more more
those just wanted to make sure all right
does anybody else have
anything for
today seeing nothing I guess we'll see
everybody on January
3D no
oh veto day all right very good next
Thursday we'll see everybody okay that
closes the executive session thanks
everybody be with me my friend which one
on the last one I was with you no
you you went along with the amendment I
what along with the amendment to get
amend I thought sure Jesus G to get to
brownie
point with my friend Jim and
nothing you voted for it too I voted
in